I want to take some time today to really go
through yesterday's Trump rally in Pennsylvania.
Not because Donald Trump did anything particularly
more unhinged than normal. It was filled with
all of the stuff that has unfortunately become
normal in presidential rallies in the Trump
era. But the reason that I want to go through
it in a little more detail than we normally
might is because of its sociological value,
how it gives us insight and understanding
into what is happening in the world of Trumpists
that exists, which I'll be perfectly honest,
as someone who lives in Boston and only occasionally
travels, uh, to, you know, rural Missouri
or these types of places where we have a bigger
concentration of trumpets and the ideology
and cult personality that's been developed
there, I think it's important for us not to
understand what's going on and to realize
that, uh, only through realizing how it all
works.
Can we actually develop a strategy, uh, that
might work to remove Donald Trump. It's really
important for us to understand that this is
a large contingent of the country here in
Boston. You know, it's very left wing. And
even the right wingers that there are are
more Romney ish right-wingers. Although there's
everything, of course, I don't want a general
generalize, but to some degree I have to generalize.
We're talking here about tens of millions
of people who in my sense a big portion of
whom, uh, could vote again for Donald Trump
in 2020 we were talking about 60 million people
in 2016 whose connection to reality and facts
and reason and decency has been severed by
this presidency. You will notice that the
Trump rally as an institution of society has
now become reminiscent of the rallies of the
great authoritarians of the 20th and 21st,
early 21st century. Now, I'm not calling Trump
Hitler.
Stop with the childish stuff. What I am saying
is that these rallies over the decades from
authoritarian strong men and particularly
ignorant, authoritarian, strong men start
to take on a similar feel and characteristic.
No dissenting voices are allowed. The audience
must be completely United, fervently behind
whatever the strong man says with no assessment
of the truth of what the strong man says.
The atmosphere has to be both sort of jovial.
But constantly on the verge of becoming violent
as well. If the wrong thing is said or if
the wrong person appears reverential towards
the dear leader, no matter what they say,
absolute and total lies stated as truth and
cheered by the audience as if they are truth,
an unsafe place for any kind of difference
of opinion. A place where everyone is constantly
judging, evaluating and monitoring the level
of commitment of those around them to the
strong man that is ranting on the stage. Anyway,
this one in Pennsylvania yesterday was really
out of control. Let's look at a few moments.
This was one of Trump's ugliest and most sickening
performances in a very long time. The more
the walls close in, the more erratic and authoritarian
he becomes. Here is Trump repeating the lie
that we weren't respected under Obama, but
now we are.
I say it, I've already said it twice tonight.
This country is so respected and we were not
respected four years ago. We will
[inaudible].
Of course, the truth is the opposite. The
U N literally laughing at Trump during his
latest UN speech, the world leaders, uh, last
week at the NATO summit, literally laughing
at Donald Trump. We are now a laughing stock.
We weren't then, but facts don't matter. Trump
later claiming that his bogus trade war is
helping people when it has done a lot of damage,
including in the state of Pennsylvania, which
we will discuss.
I've taken the toughest ever action against
China's trade abuses. They want to make a
deal so bad and we're doing well with the
deal, but they want to make a deal. Please
make a deal. We don't want to pay terrorists
anymore. Please, please Zack shore, our steel
towers, steel mills in Pennsylvania are roaring
back to life and us seal has just announced
a $1 billion investment in Mon Valley works
in Pittsburgh. You know that right?
Everything is the opposite. No one in the
crowd has any clue what Donald Trump is talking
about and then Trump tells the crowd that
they have had their best year ever. He tells
the Pennsylvania crowd that Pennsylvania has
had its best year ever.
We're in Pennsylvania. You had the single
best year that you've ever had in the history
of our country. Not bad.
Now, this is not only wrong, it's meaningless
in a sense, like what does it mean that a
state had its best year ever? But the reality
is that Pennsylvania lost about a hundred,
about 10,000 factory jobs. Trump's own trade
policy has been crushing their steel industry,
crushing their manufacturing industries, which
are important industries in Pennsylvania,
particularly outside of Philadelphia, outside
of some of the biggest cities. At one point
during the rally, a female protester with
a pink sign said, uh, had a pink sign that
said, grabbing power back. This is a reference
of course to Trump talking about grabbing
women by the, the signs saying, we're going
to grab a power back. The crowd. Notice her
started booing. Trump said, get her out. They
threw her out very quickly. The crowd will
turn on you at these rallies.
Yesterday, the justice department's inspector
general released a report detailing the outrageous,
scandalous and unprecedented abuses of power.
Get her out, get around
[inaudible]
Trump, of course, attacking impeachment, calling
everything disgusting and a fraud.
Now that the Russia witch hunt is dead, a
big, fat, disgusting fraud. The congressional
Democrats are pushing the impeachment, which
aren't having to do with Ukraine
[inaudible],
but that's already failing. You saw there
so-called articles of impeachment. Today people
are saying they're not even a crime. What
happened? All of these horrible things. You
remember bribery and this and that. It goes,
where are they? They send these two things
and not even a crime.
Trump then combining their two most common
defenses in one go, which is, this didn't
happen and this isn't a crime. It did happen,
but it's not a crime. The crowd doesn't realize
it or they don't care. Donald Trump very often
will do this. He will say, Oh, this thing
that they're saying I did, I definitely didn't
do it, and by the way, legal experts will
often quote people like Mark Levin and Greg
Jarrett from Fox news. Legal experts say,
there's no crime. There's no crime. Wait,
hold on. Did you not do it or did you do it?
But there is no crime. It doesn't matter.
Trump. Then galvanizing anger against the
media in general. Another common authoritarian
technique of uniting the crowd angrily against
any, uh, attempted check on the lies and the
wrongdoing of the strong man and Trump going
after the dishonest corrupt media
to say this, look, and I always have to say
this, you have some really great journalists
and you have some honest publications, but
not too many of them. I have to be honest
with you. The legislator, well, you know that,
does anybody think the media is honest?
[inaudible]
does anybody think they're totally corrupted,
dishonest.
And then Donald Trump calling the FBI scum.
That's a nice one, right? Referring to top
level cops and dirty players who are leaving,
referring to intelligence officials, uh, people
at the FBI, so on and so forth.
And if you look at what's happened with the
scum that's leaving the very top of government
people that others used to say, Oh, that's
what that dirty, these were dirty cops. These
were dirty players. You take a look at what's
going on. There's 21 of them already and I'm
not even doing, they're just leaving because
they got caught. Like nobody ever got caught.
[inaudible]
now at one point, it actually goes beyond
parody. Trump has ignored the constitutional
oversight mechanisms that the house has, ignoring
subpoenas to people that work for him, directing
people not to testify, uh, violating the emoluments
clause endlessly. And he closes the rally
with we support, protect and defend the constitution,
which is sometimes a meaningless bit of a
dribble that we hear from elected officials.
But with Trump, it happens to also be extremely
opposed to the truth. Indistinguishable from
parody. Take a look
[inaudible]
bubble. We will never stop fighting for the
sacred values that bind us together as one
America, one great country, one America. We
support, protect and defend the constitution
of the United States. We stand with the incredible
heroes of law enforcement.
We also have some video from interviews with
Trumpists outside of the rally, and some of
you may be eating as you listen to the show
or watch the watch the show. So I don't want
to spoil your appetite with too much of this
stuff, but it won't come as a surprise that
the Trumpists that are interviewed, they repeat
the exact same talking points often verbatim
that have been fed to them by the dear leader.
They have no idea what's going on. And I actually
fear feel more sad than angry about this.
It's sad because if we taught critical thinking,
if we taught philosophy, if we taught civic
starting, you know, in middle school, a lot
of this stuff, a lot of these people would
never fall for this stuff to begin with. But
listen to how this guy repeats Trump's phrases.
Word for word in defending Donald Trump.
You start on it. What gets me fired up is
the impeachment hoax. Okay? Other issues,
jobs, unemployment, the lowest black unemployment,
lowest women's. Although those things are
all positive, but when you have such a hoax,
when we all saw the Washington compost 19
minutes into his election into 2016 when he
was elected, they said the impeachment process
is started now 19 minutes in, are you kidding
me? And then all this here and now they said
they have the two things. They're going to,
uh, obstruction of Congress. Not even obstruction
of justice, but obstruction of Congress and
abusive power, which that's a big joke because
they talk about quid pro quo. I see the video
of Joe Biden saying, if you don't have fired-up
prosecutor, I'm leaving in six hours. You're
not getting the billions that's on video.
And they say, Oh, he didn't do anything. And
yet the president asked the question, though,
I'm not a, I'm not an English major, but the
president, if you read the transcript, please
read the transcript. He asked a question if
you would do me a favor, do me a favor. If
so, he's giving the ball to the Ukrainian
president.
It's a combination of weaponized ignorance,
red herrings, misunderstandings of the facts
refers to the transcript, which of course
we don't have because they didn't release
a transcript. They released a little excerpt.
It's all word for word. What Trump gives them.
They repeat in unwavering defense of the dear
leader. So what's the takeaway? The takeaways
are, we still have a country that is a Western
democracy on paper and in principle, but for
half of the country or almost half of the
country, 40% of the country, the dynamics,
the feel, the style, it's becoming what we
see in authoritarian strongman nations, and
it should scare the hell out of us if it hasn't
already. Number two, we can't win by talking
sense into those people. We can't talk them
into voting for someone other than Trump.
Now I understand this is a rally. These are
the rabid supporters who don't care about
the facts.
Now, sure, the rally crowds are crazier and
wackier than the people who just go to work
and then they consider themselves Republicans
and election day comes around and they might
vote for Donald Trump, but in either case,
we've got to focus on get out the vote. We
have to galvanize our side because a lot of
these people are not reachable and it is a
waste of time to try to convince them at the
individual level. I don't think we should
do it. I think we should work on, get out
the vote, voter registration, preventing voter
suppression and foreign meddling in the election.
Let me know what you think. Very depressing.
Leave a reply. If you're watching on YouTube,
send me a tweet at Dee Pacman. Follow me,
by the way,
way on Twitter at the Pacman as well,